[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous de débat de chronique et de
reportage comme tous les jours à 18h et
22h sur Public Sénat pour donner du sens
à l'actualité grâce à nos invités
experts et ce soir c'est la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel que l'on va
décortiquer les sages présidés par
Laurent Fabius ont décidé de lourdement
censurer la loi immigration votée le 19
décembre dernier la plupart des mesures
porté par la droite parlementaire ont
été retoqué que reste-t-il du texte
initial quelles seront les conséquences
politiques de cette décision certaines
mesures prenées par le parti LR
peuvent-elles réapparaître dans d'autres
textes réponses dans une minute et puis
en seconde partie de ce sens public
c'est un nouveau rendez-vous que l'on
vous propose jusqu'au 9 juin date des
élections européennes que fait l'Europe
on se posera cette question simple sur
plusieurs thèmes l'immigration de
nouveau mais aussi la transition
écologique la gestion de crise la
transparence et pour commencer
l'énergie la facture d'électricité sur
les tarifs heure plein heure creuse va
augmenter de 9,8 % au 1er février sur
les tarifs de base 8,6 % nos factures
d'électricité augmentent à partir du 1er
février est-ce en partie à cause des
règlements des mesures européennes
peut-on s'en affranchir de ces règles et
à quel prix réponse dans 3o qu4 d'heure
mais d'abord
les détails de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel et les réactions au
Sénat avec Jonathan Dupriez Adrien pin
et Quentin Calmet c'est une décision aux
allures de sentence pour le texte
immigration le Conseil constitutionnel a
décidé de censurer une très large partie
de ce projet de loi 40 % des mesures de
ce texte hautement inflammable sont donc
retoqué en premier lieu les Sages ont
fait tomber 32 cavaliers législatifs des
mesures jugées trop éloignées du texte
originel exite donc le durcissement de
l'accès aux prestations sociales du
regroupement familial ou encore de
l'instauration d'une caution retour pour
les étudiants étrangers mais cette large
censure est surtout un revers de taille
pour la droite sénatoriale à l'origine
du durcissement de ce texte elle est
contestable elle est absolument
contestable et finalement le Conseil
constitionnel interdit au
législateurs de prendre des mesures
qu'ilintègre à une politique que nous
voulions intégrer une politique globale
efficace de contrôle de la migration
c'est quelque part un dénis du pouvoir
du Parlement du pouvoir du législateur
aussi le Conseil constitutionnel a fait
tomber trois mesures sur le fond la
tenue d'un débat annuel au Parlement
pour fixer des quôas migratoires le
relevé de photos et d'empreintte sans le
consentement des clandestins ou encore
le changement de procédure d'examen d'un
titre de séjour la censure de ces
articles revigore en tout cas les
parlementaires de gauche vend debout
contre ce texte et à l'initiative de
deux des quatre recours auprès du
Conseil constitutionnel c'est une bonne
nouvelle je me réjouis de cette décision
du du Conseil constitutionnel on ne
s'assoit pas sur la constitution et sur
nos principes fondamentaux et je suis
heureux que le Conseil constitutionnel a
rappelé par exemple que la préférence
nationale n'est pas soluble dans la
République et dans les valeurs de la
République et en l'occurrence je pense
que c'est aussi une une claque
monumentale pour le président de la
République pour les macronistes qui ont
fait le choix de courir à après la
droite et et l'extrême droite le texte
conserve toutefois un large volet de
simplification des procédures pour
l'expulsion des étrangers délinquants
notamment ce que souhaitait le
gouvernement mais cette large censure
place Emmanuel Macron face à un dilemme
cornélien promulgué en l'état un texte
amputé ou le soumettre à une nouvelle
délibération du
Parlement on analyse les conséquences
politiques de ce camoufl infligé par le
Conseil constitutionnel avec
annecharline Bina bonsoir
constitutionnaliste Jean gar bonsoir
historien président du Comité d'histoire
parlementaire et auteur de ce livre
jours heureux quand les Français rêvêtre
ensemble chez Paillot Michel auouin
bonsoir bienvenue à vous ancien
directeur de l'intégration des étrangers
et des naturalisations au ministère de
de l'intérieur et vous publiez le défi
d'être français au presse de la cité Tam
tranui bonsoir Tam bienvenue
éditorialiste politique ce soir pour
pour sens public question générale pour
commencer Charline Bina lour de censure
large censure camouflé quel quel terme
employez-vous pour qualifier cette
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
alors il y a la tentation de parler de
lourde censure puisque en effet bon on a
quand même 40 % du du texte qui est
amputé hein il faut le dire à la suite
de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel mais je crois qu'on
aurait tort de parler de camoufler pour
la majorité ou de considérer que le
Conseil constitionnel a rappelé que nos
principes fondamentaux et nos droits de
l'homme s'opposer à cette loi parce que
en réalité il faut
ou c'est un camouflé pour le travail
parlementaire en gros la leçon qu'on va
retenir c'est que le Conseil
constitionnel censure l'essentiel de la
loi par rapport à des motifs de
procédure ce qui nous prouve tout
simplement ce que nous avons dit depuis
le départ que la majorité relative c'est
un art difficile que apparemment cette
majorité ne maîtrise pas complètement
puisque les accords auraient dû être
faits en amont dans une législation qui
tienne la route qui soit cohérente et ce
que le Conseil constitutionnel nous dit
ce soir c'est rajouter durcir après coup
ça fait perdre la cohérence à l'ensemble
et finalement c'est sur ce motif là que
tout tombe donc on n' pas vraiment une
décision immigration aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas si on peut conditionner les
allocations on ne sait pas si on peut
changer le droit du regroupement
familial on ne sait pas tout ça parce
que le Conseil n'y a pas donné de
réponse tout simplement parce que dit ça
n'avait pas sa place dans ce texte
n'avait pas sa place dans ce texte là je
rajoute même que le gouvernement
pourrait reprendre demain la même loi
tout simplement en la discutant un petit
peu mieux dès le départ donc on n pas de
réponse sur le fond on a un camouflé par
rapport à une procédure qui até très mal
tenue h
n so évidemment il y aura beaucoup de
réactions politiques pendant ce premier
débat des réactions en direct on sera
dans un instant avec Patrick caner le
président du groupe socialiste ici au
Sénat on sera également avec
Jean-Philippe dobress pour le parti LR
lui aussi sénateur évidemment LR et puis
on vous diffusera de larges réactions
qui ont été glanées dans les couloirs du
Sénat dans la dans la journée tiens une
première réaction sur sur X le réseau
social signé Jordan Bardella le
président du Rassemblement national et
candidat aux élections européennes tête
de liste RN par un coup de force des
juges avec le soutien du président de la
République lui-même le Conseil
constitutionnel censure les mesures de
fermieuté les plus approuvées par le
Français la loi immigration est mornée
la seule solution c'est le référendum
sur l'immigration on y reviendra sur la
question du référendum mais cette
expression loi immigration mornée
jean-garic est-ce que vous la reprenez à
votre compte est-ce que cette loi
finalement on peut se dire qu'elle sera
jamais appliquée qu'elle est mornée pas
du tout non ça va peut-être vous vous
surprendre d'abord je je regrette un peu
qu'un le président d'un des des grands
partis candidats notamment aux élections
européennes à la présidence de la
République emploie de de tel terme par
rapport à une institution qui est quand
même malgré tout un des piliers de la la
5e République qui est le Conseil
constitutionnel qui mérite certes d'être
critiqué peut-être refondé beaucoup de
juristes le le pensent et je suis
finalement plutôt
de de leur côté mais en tout cas c'est
un c'est un pilier de la 5e République
quant à dire que c'est une une loi
mornée je dirais que non parce que en
fait si vous voyez si vous extrayez tout
ce qui a été censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel vous revenez finalement
au texte du Gouvernement alors dire que
ce texte du du gouvernement est un texte
finalement qui était incomplet et qui a
mon sens était mal présenté je rejoins
Charlen là-dessus je je pense qu'on on
s'y est très mal pris pour faire aboutir
cette loi qui était une loi Fourtout et
qui a étit et dont le caractère
incohérent a été renforcé par le le
positionnement des des républicains mais
en revanche ce qui relève notamment de
la du de des métiers en tension de la
régularisation des étrangers dans les
métiers en tension qui était important
dans le projet du du gouvernement à
l'origine c'était ce fameux article 3
est maintenu donc finalement si vous
voulez il y a une une forme de réussite
s politique à très court terme du
gouvernement qui réussit à faire passer
son texte tel qu'il était avant la
négociation qui nous a beaucoup je
dirais perturbé avec avec les
républicains Michel auoin vous avez une
expérience ministériel vous avez
accompagné beaucoup de ministres de
l'intérieur de différents couleurs
politiques cette loi dans dans la
version on va dire j'allais dire
ratiboisé c'est un peu trivial mais
quand même c'est ce que l'impression
qu'on a 40 % des du du texte ok est-ce
qu'elle peut être efficace d'après vous
on a un gros problème par que c'est
quand même ça l'objectif oui elle est
sans doute efficace mais est-ce qu'elle
est efficace au départ c'estàd
ouais dans sa première version c'est
quand même une loi qui disait j'ose pas
dire tout et son contraire mais c'est
vrai avec des dispositions qui étaient
assez contradictoires les unes avec les
autres
euh le vrai problème aujourd'hui de
cette de ce qui reste de la loi c'est
c'est comment les politiques vont
l'expliquer aux Français parce que c'est
c'est ça qui est incompréhensible pour
les Français je pense qu'il y avait une
majorité l'opinion qui était connu sur
le sujet et et qui va qui ressort pas du
tout du des débats et et de la de la
censure de conseil constitutionnel don
je pense qu'on le le le globalement non
seulement le gouvernement mais la
totalité des hommes politiques vont
avoir du mal à faire comprendre quel est
cette décision qui renvoie quand même
aussi aux Herms du débat parlementaire
d'une certaine façon puisqu'on a
introduit des éléments tous'étaaiit pas
desstiné à être censuré mais enfin on a
quand même introduit des éléments dont
on savait per pertinemment qu'ils
allaient être censurés alors on a deux
parlementaires avec nous je vais
commencer avec Marc Philippe d'bress je
vous ai appelé Jean-Philippe tout à
l'heure dans la précipitation et je m'en
excuse évidemment Marc Philip deobes
sénateur Alire du Nord et vice-président
de la commission des lois est-ce que
vous prenez cette décision du Conseil
constitutionnel bonsoir Comme un
camouflé pour le travail parlementaire
et notamment le vôre celui de des
sénateur LR et des et des députés LR cl
clairement c'est pour moi ce n'est pas
un camouflé sur le fond c'est un
camoufl alors on a perdu le le son avec
Marc Philippe dobress qu'on devrait
retrouver dans un court instant je pense
qu'en parlant il a dû désactiver le le
micro de son de son ordinateur est-ce
que ça marche de nouveau on essae très
vite
sinon bon on vous entend pas donc on va
régler ça et on on va rejoindre Patrick
caner qui est lui aussi en en attente je
le vois dans dans notre écran de de
contrôle Patrick canner donc président
du groupe socialiste à à l'Assemblée au
Sénat et sénateur du Nord tiens une
question toute simple est-ce que j'ai
j'ai lu que
euh le le Parti socialiste demandait le
retrait de la loi est-ce que vous le
faites vous
aussi vous savez le le président a les
moyens de ne pas promulguer euh ce texte
qui effectivement a été ratiboisé je
reprends l'expression qui a été utilisée
sur votre plateau c'est un mauvais texte
texte sur le fond même s'il y a des
dispositions qui ont été validées par le
Conseil constitutionnel mais sur la
forme le Conseil finalement il a fait
quoi il a censuré un mauvais travail
parlementaire mauvais travail
parlementaire qui a été initié par la
droite que représente sur ce plateau
Marc Philippe debress que je que je
salue mais un mauvais travail
parlementaire qui a été cautionné par le
gouvernement qui finalement pour avoir
un accord politique politicien à accepté
vraiment de mettre un genou à terre et
d'accepter les condition de de LR vous
savez moi j'ai assisté à la commission
mix paritaire j'ai vu ce ce jeu de DUP
pendant des heures et des heures assez
honteux d'ailleurs assez permettez-moi
l'expression moche moche pour ce qu'on
imagine être le bon travail d'une
institution aussi importante au sein de
de la République donc le Conseil a fait
son travail il a fait son œuvre
d'ailleurs c'est pas une surprise qui
s'est passé était tellement attendu
simplement aujourd'hui on crée une
situation qui devient dangereuse quand
je lis quand j'écoute monsieur Bardella
parler de de juges
[Musique]
qui voilà donc on est quasiment devant
des facciieux qui remettent en cause le
bon fonctionnement de nos institutions
et ça c'est quand même très très grave
Marc Philippe dabress j'espère que le
son fonctionne cette fois-ci je reprends
l'expression marché de dupe en décembre
est-ce que finalement vous avez le
sentiment
que votre parti a a a joué ce jeu a
participé à un marché de
dupe c'est c'est moi à moi que vous vous
adressez là c'est à vous que je pose
cette question mar reconnecté oui on on
a pour moi un camouflé sur la démocratie
parlementaire je suis un vieux
parlementaire j'ai participé à plus
d'une vingtaine de révision de la
Constitution la dernière important en
2008 on dit bien qu'un cavalier
législatif doit avoir il y a un droit
d'AM tout parlementaire et qu'il faut
qu'il y ait un lien direct ou indirect
avec le texte excusez-moi de vous dire
que sur les 32 articles qui sont
considérés comme des cavaliers
législatifs à chaque fois il y a au
moins un lien direct avec le texte donc
il y a une décision qui est plus
politique que juridique de mon point de
vue je conteste pas sur les trois
articles sur le fond qu' son sur le
Conseil constitutionnel il est dans son
rôle mais sur les 32 cavaliers
législatifs je le conteste formellement
et je dis que la réponse c'est que pour
qu'on nit pas le sentiment d'une
impuissance publique totale dans la
population qui soutenait largement les
mesures que nous présentions il faut
qu'il y ait une nouvelle loi qui soit
présentée et à terme il faudra ce que
nous disions depuis le départ une
révision de la Constitution donc c'est
un camouflé pour la démocratie
parlementaire merci beaucoup restez avec
nous j'aurai certainement l'occasion de
vous faire réagir dans un court instant
dans ce débat mais c'est très
intéressant Tam tranui parce que on voit
que finalement le Conseil
constitutionnel il était forcé de rendre
sa décision sous sous pression des
partis politiques on vient on vient de
l'entendre ici oui on a vu aujourd'hui
désormais bien c'est sur le Conseil
constitutionnel que se concentrre les
critiques notamment les critiques de la
droite on va voir ce qu'a dit
Bruno retaillot ses déclarations sur X
puisque manifestement ce n'est plus le
Parlement qui fait la loi dans ce pays
je propose que Gabriel àal face sa
déclaration de politique générale devant
le Conseil constitutionnel une
déclaration de politique générale qui
est prévue donc la semaine prochaine et
il dénonce également la République des
juges on a entendu i les propos de
Jordane Bardella on le sentait venir he
ces critiques de Bruno retaillot déjà
depuis ce matin écoutez par exemple ce
qu' disait sur France Inter ce que
j'attends du Conseil constitutionnel
c'est c'est qu'il s'en tiennne au droit
à la constitution toute la Constitution
rien que la Constitution c'est la seule
façon pour le Conseil constitutionnel
pour les sages du Conseil
constitutionnel d'éviter la critique
jusqu'ici tout va bien le Conseil
constitutionnel ne doit pas sortir de
son indépendance de sa neutralité ne
doit pas se faire l'écho du débat
ambiant mais dans la même interview il
disait ça quelques minutes plus tard
écouter s'il venait à défaire très
largement notre texte il enlèverait
toute possibilité au Parlement en
réalité de reprendre le contrôle des
flux migratoires et donc on a entendu
hein le patron des sénateurs les
républicains qui a aussi rajouté que le
Conseil constitutionnel et bien s'il
censurait le le le texte immigration et
bien il faudrait revoir la Constitution
ce qu'a dit également Marc Philippe
dobress tout à l'heure preuve que ce
qu'il a contendé du Conseil
constitutionnel ce n'était pas seulement
de s'ent tenir au droit comme il le
disait dans un premier temps ce n'était
pas seulement de l'impartialité mais
c'était avant tout qu'il donne raison à
son camp hein on connaît un peu la
situation de la biche un agïste c'est
quelqu'un qui ne pense pas à à moi
version Bruno retaillo quelqu'un de
partial c'est quelqu'un qui ne pense pas
comme moi c'est comme ça aussi qu'on
pouvait entendre ce qu'il disait ce
matin oui alors on reviendra parce qu'il
y a d'autres qui d'autres politiques qui
ne se privent pas de de de critiquer ou
de taper sur le conseiloui on a une
année où le Conseil constitutionnel on a
entendu des vertes et des pamures sur
son indépendance avec la réforme de
retraite aussiou on y reviendra en
détail dans dans un instant mais Anne
Charlen beina on on on on pose cette
question de l'impartialité des des juges
du Conseil constitutionnel qu' qu'on
surnomme les sages d'illeurs c'est
plutôt nous les journalistes qui qui
employons C pression bon il faut
rappeler ils sont nommés par des
personnalités politiques par le
Président de la République par le
président les présidents des des deux
assemblées donc ils font forcément aussi
de la politique alors c'était à peu près
certain qu'on aurait ce débat ce soir
quel que soit l'issue de la décision
parce que précisément je pense que les
conditions de nomination de nos juges
constitutionnels les conditions aussi de
son contrôle a priori c'està-dire celui
juste après le vote des textes dont nous
parlons aujourd'hui sont des conditions
très inédites dans tout toute l'Europe
proche et des conditions sûrement
hautement criticables en tout cas d'un
point de vue démocratique je pense que
c'est très difficile de faire passer
aujourd'hui dans l'opinion l'idée que
neuf de nos juges n'ont pas à avoir de
compéten juridique pour être recruté
c'est vrai que ça pose des problèmes
néanmins je dois ajouter que dans
beaucoup d'autres démocraties proches la
nomination par le pouvoir politique
n'est pas une preuve de manque
d'impartialité bien au contraire Robert
Badinter disait on a à l'égard de nos
autorités de nomination un devoir d'un
gratitude c'est-à-dire qu'à partir du
moment où vous entrez dans cette
institution vous faites primer le droit
sur la politique et je crois c'est
Dominique Schnapper qui était ancienne
membres et sociologu qui parlait
justement d'une institution qui
travaillait ses membres de l'Intérieur
c'est-à-dire que à partir du moment où
vous habituez un peu à travailler ce
vocabulaire juridique à être dans
l'exercice du testte et bien vous perdez
petit à petit cette coloration alors
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui les critiques sur
la nomination doivent continuer oui je
le pense est-ce que ce conseil
constitionnel doit se réformer oui je le
pense je pense d'ailleurs qu'il devrait
s'appelait cours constitutionnelle comme
on lui a dénié ce droit en 2008 mais je
pense aussi que il ne faut pas qu'à
chaque décision on se remettent à
reparler du critère organique parce que
les décisions en tant que telles elles
doivent être respectées pour ce qu'elles
sont c'est-à-dire tout simplement une
confrontation de la loi à la
Constitution qui ne donne aucune
solution à notre politique publique et
donc aujourd'hui on nallait pas avoir de
solution sur l'asile quoi qu'il se passe
dans la r pens on l'a bien compris il y
a quand même il s'est passé quand même
quelque chose d'un peu par particulier
je vous posais un peu la la même
question à à tous les deux c'est le fait
que le président sa première ministre
saisisse eux aussi le Conseil
constitionnel il y avait d'abord les
parti gauche et et franchement c'était
logique vu le la tonalité du texte
est-ce que à partir du moment où où
Emmanuel Macron cisit le Conseil
constitutionnel il y a pas déjà quelque
chose qui est un peu est-ce qu'on tort
pas un peu le le le principe
d'utilisation de fonctionnement de de de
cette Cour constitutionnelle c'est vrai
que ça n ça n'est pas courant et c'est
vrai effectivement que ça traduit
effectivement l'échec du processus
parlementaire à partir et et je veux
dire même du processus exécutif d'abord
du projet de l'exécutif et ensuite du TR
de sa faiblesse aussi ça traduit sa
faiblesse à imposeridé donc il s'est
défaussé sur le Conseil
constitutionnel s'est défaussé c'est
c'est l'expression que moi j'ent pas
quand on m'interroge là-dessus il s'est
défaussé de sa responsabilité par
rapport à un piège parce que au fond
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il s'est passé
que pour arriver à faire passer un un
texte qui correspondait à une demande
sociale ce qui a été dit c'estàdire que
la plupart des mesure de de ce texte
elles sont appuyées et souhaité par la
majorité des Français mais comme elles
sont en contradiction avec l'esprit
initial avec ce que représente on va
dire le le macronisme qui et à droite et
à gauche voir la le fameux article 3
dont je parlais tout à l'heure et bien
il y avait forcément quelque chose là
qui allait qui allait coincer à un
moment et comme on a voulu malgré tout
faire passer ce texte mal ficelé et qui
qui à mon sens aurait dû faire l'objet
de plusieurs projets de de loi
différents et bien on est allé à cette à
cette espèce de de défausse et qui fait
aujourd'hui peser toutes ces critiques
et et c'est vrai qu'elles sont pas elles
sont pas nouvelles sur ce Conseil
constitutionnel qui malgré tout pour
avoir discuté avec un certain nombre de
ses membres pour pour les connaître
notamment ceux qui sont des juristes
essaent de faire le leur travail le plus
consciencieusement possible rapid on
rappelle quand même que le Conseil
constitutionnel a lui-même tensé le
président de la République au mois de
janvier au moment des vœuxs et que donc
le Conseil constitutionnel lui-même n'a
pas du tout a cette procédure où en
transformer en quelque sorte ce qu' dit
Laurent Fabius en cours d'appel du
Parlement c'est pas du tout là son but
c'est pas du tout là sa fonction ou
effectivement votre avis oui moi à mon
avis c'est
c'estés c'est une position sarenu à vrai
dire que le Président je sais pas si
c'est totalement inédit j'ai pas mémoire
de ce type de saisine mais c'est
complètementrenu que le président
saisisse lui-même il a le droit
évidemment le Conseil consti il faut
rapper au moins la
une saisine blanche avec aucun point
précis seulement enfin l'ensemble Tex
c'est c'est d'autant plus enrenu que les
parlementaires avaient eux tout à fait
le droit ils sont complètement légitimes
surtout ceux deopposition à le saisir
donc c'est vraiment une saisine qui
était inutile d'ailleurs le Conseil
constitionel s'autoaisit lui-même une
fois qu'il est saisi il examine la
totalité des des articles il le rappelle
d'ailleurs dans ses décision alors c'est
ce grenu et ça va mettre euh le reste du
quinquena de Monsieur Macron dans une
situation assez particulière quand même
parce que ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que un projet de loi déposé par le
Gouvernement ne peut pas être débattu
par l'opposition ne peut pas être
corrigé par l'opposition parce que on va
systématiquement lui retoquer l'argument
du Conseil constitutionnel qui est que
les les articles ajoutés lors de la
discussion n'était pas dans le projet
initial c'est ce qui écrit le Conseil
constitutionnel donc ça veut dire qu'il
y a plus de débat possible et comme il a
pas de majorité é au Parlement comment
est-ce qu'il va faire fonctionner la vie
démocratique dans ce pays jusqu'au bout
je trouve ça je sais pas s'il a bien
mesuré et si son entourage a bien mesuré
les effets de cette juste une incidente
mais il faut quand même rappeler que
depuis 2022 60 % des lois proposé par le
l'exécutif ont été votés quand même ce
qui veut dire que on va pas forcément se
retrouver dans ce cas de figure sur tous
les projs je je reviens vers vers nos
deux invités en en duplexe peut-être
pour commencer Patrick caner euh quelle
leçon les Français vont tirer de ce
qu'on peut appeler un fiasco législatif
mais peut-être aussi exécutif quelle
leçons les Français vont tirer de cette
séquence d'après
vous déjà les Français vont avoir du mal
à comprendre ce qui s'est passé
euh est-ce qu'ils vont comprendre la
duplicité de l'exécutif et notamment
d'Emmanuel Macron qui pour avoir une
majorité coûte que coûte à sacrifier
finalement ses principes en espérant
voilà que le conseil et il l'a fait
serait la cour d'appel totalement
anormale du travail parlementaire donc
c'est un fiasco du du gouvernement c'est
une faute politique pour ne pas dire
morale du président de de la République
on ne joue pas finalement avec des
sujets aussi sensibles comme cela a été
fait moi je me souviens de de ma
première rencontre avec Olivier duopt et
Géral daranin il nous avaiit présenté
leur textees en disant c'est un
équilibre voilà il y a une partie euh
juste celle de la régularisation des 100
papiers qui sont sur les métiers en
tenstion et puis une une partie plus du
éégalienne pour expulser plus facilement
des délinquants de de étranger donc bon
il y avait une sorte de cohérence mais
la faute initiale c'est d'avoir mélangé
les les deux objectifs en même temps et
d'avoir encore une fois cherché une
majorité à à contreesens finalement j'ai
bien bien entendu mon collègue et ami
Marc Philippe debress mais les dadons de
la farce CLR dans cette affaire qui ont
qui ont cru qu'ils auraient pu passer en
force auprès d'Emmanuel Macron et il se
retrouve gros gens comme devant donc
voilà le le le ce qui est en train de se
passer est-ce que les Français le
comprendront moi je je crois qu'on ne
joue pas avec le moral des français
surtout qui débat actuellement avec des
manœuvres politiciennes telles que Cell
que nous avons pu vivre depuis quelques
semaines autre réaction celle de
d'Olivier fort le premier secrétaire du
Parti socialiste qui dit sa satisfaction
après la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel et il dit je le cite le
gouvernement portera comme une tâche
indélébile l'appel à voter une loi
s'alignant sur les positions historiques
de l'extrême droite sous la pression de
LR Marc Philippe dobress et ce sera ma
ma dernière question est-ce que un vous
pouvez répondre évidemment au au au
sénateur canner mais est-ce que vous
vous sentez les dindons de la farce et
de est-ce que Infiné tout ça ne fait pas
le jeu du rassemblement national mais
moi je pense que ça fait le jeu des
extrêmes parce que un pays vous savez
ici en province au bord de l'explosion
sociale on est dans la même situation
qu'en 1789 vous voyez ce qui se passe
avec les agriculteurs demain ce sera les
les transporteurs routier après-demain
ce sera le bâtiment et les travaux
publics et donc dans ce contexte là
d'extrême violence sociale on a une
décision d'impuissance publique
évidemment que ça va renforcer les
extrêmes et je redis que juridiquement
le Conseil constitutionnel fait une
acception très restrictive du lien
indirect entre un projet de loi et des
apports parlementaires il va au-delà de
son rôle donc juridiquement je le
conteste mais surtout politiquement la
décision qu'il vient de prendre va
renforcer l'idée dans toute la
population que finalement ces
parlementaires ils ne servent à rien ils
sont impuissants ils peuvent pas
résoudre nos problèmes on a tout essayé
on va essayer les extrêmes et ben
bonjour au milieu de cette année vous
allez aller voir et si les Français
constatent que finalement ils ne croient
plus en rien à la politique ils iront
dans une éme sociale je suis
trèsenir si le gouvernement ne reprend
pas la main et ne présente pas une
nouvelle loi qui reprend tout tout parti
de ce qui a été exprimé comme un
cavalier législatif et bien vous allez
voir il y aura une réaction très vive du
peuple français parce qu'on le dépossède
de ce qu'il attendait de la démocratie
parlementaire vos arguments à l'un et à
l'autre merci à tous les deux merci
Patrick caner merci Marc Philippe dabz
d'avoir réagi en direct dans ce sens
public on parlait des critiques qui se
qui qui pleuvent en quelque sorte sur le
Conseil constitutionnel il y en a de de
tous les côtés rappelez-nous quelques
quelques exemples oui donc on vient
d'entendre notamment la droite qui est
très mécontente et bien taper sur le
Conseil constitutionnel c'est une
activité à laquelle tous se sont adonnés
cette année rappelez-vous et bien l'an
dernier la réforme des retêtes
globalement validée par le Conseil
constitutionnel Jean-Luc lchon dégagne
directement sur Twitter c'était encore
Twitter à l'époque la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel montre qu'il est
plus attentif au besoins de la monarchie
présidentielle qu'à ceux du peuple
souverain donc après la réforme des
retraites c'était bien la gauche qui
l'avait mauvaise on cette fois-ci c'est
la droite on ne peut pas soupçonner
Alain Jupé Laurent Fabius de ne pas
vouloir se fâcher avec leur ex-fille
politique et comme Laurent Fabius aime
le rappeler c'est parce que leur
carrière politique malgré tout ce qu'on
a pu dire elle est quand même loin
derrière eux et Laurent fabus qui cite
volontiers Robert Badinter
l'ex-président du Conseil Conti
constitutionnel qui outre le fait
d'avoir parlé de son devoir
d'ingratitude ce que vous avez pas ce
que vous avez rappelé Anne Charlen dit
aussi être indépendant c'est n'avoir
rien à redouter ni à espérer et alors
les sages ils sont également accusés
d'être du côté du président de la
République cette fois-ci et il faut dire
que c'est ce qu'on a expliqué les prise
de position du gouvernement n'ont pas
aidé lorsque bien plusieurs ministres au
mois de décembre ont déclaré que de
nombreuses dispositions voulues par LR
avait été adopté par la majorité en
sachant qu'elle serait censurée c'était
en fait en fait le rôle du législateur
de ne pas voter des mesures s'il les
savait d'emblé inconstitutionnel au lieu
de ça le gouvernement a négocié avec LR
une loi pour qu'elle soit adoptée avant
de dire au final qu'il s'était bouché le
nez qu'il balançait désormais la patate
chaude au Conseil constitutionnel
résultat le Conseil constitutionnel lui
a donné raison avec cette très forte
censure mais sa STR par sa stratégie
passée la majorité présidentielle a
remis une pièce dans la machine et
alimenté un petit peu plus et bien ce
procès en légitimité du Conseil
constitutionnel merci Tam autre réaction
vraiment dans la F de cette décision du
Conseil constitionnel qui est intervenu
en en fin d'après-midi celle du ministre
de l'intérieur c'est également sur le
réseau social x loi immigration le
Conseil constitutionnel valide alors
écoutez bien l'intégralité du texte du
Gouvernement du gouvernement jamais un
texte n'a prévu autant de moyens pour
expulser les délinquants autant d'exigen
pour l'intégration des étrangers le
gouvernement prend acte comme j'ai pu
l'indiquer lors des débats de la censure
de nombreux articles ajoutés au
Parlement pour non respect de la
procédure
parlementaire Anne Charl beina la aussi
enfin bon on a dit jeux de dupe on peut
dire cynisme il y a plein d'expressions
qu'on peut
utiliser ce soir euh ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'on peut
imaginer après les propos de Gérald
armanin euh voilà le gouvernement
appliquit ce
texte le Puil y a des demandes pour le
le le mettre de côté ou alors faire
revoter d'autres d'autres élés alors le
président de la République a en face de
lui deux choix promulgué sans les
dispositions amputées
ou refaire voter le Parlement ou
abandonner tout simplement donc TR euh
mais euh je doute fortement qu'il
abandonne en cours de route et pour moi
ce ce ce projet de loi tel qu'il est
revenu un peu à l'initiale et bien sera
évidemment
appliqué je ne suis pas sûr que le
ministre de l'Intérieur le président de
la République et la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale ressorte vraiment
gagnant de de cette alternative d'avoir
mis le Conseil constitutionnel en en
passe de décider pour eux parce que vous
vous le soullignez cette acception qu'il
a eu du lien des amendements avec le
texte va quand même
euh vient empêcher beaucoup à mon avis
cette majorité de de continuer à
gouverner déjà que c'était très
difficile là les accords avec LR
risquent d'être encore plus difficilees
à obtenir les amendements sur les textes
difficiles à créer en terme de lien avec
le texte donc j'ai le sentiment que la
majorité est encore plus dans une
impasse maintenant qu'avant la décision
du Conseil Constit
ça apprendra peut-être à cette majorité
à faire respecter la Constitution avant
de saisir la Haute instance géralin qui
qui se félicite mais Jean gar il est
quand même très fragilisé il était déjà
au mois de décembre dans les conditions
dans lesquelles ça s'est passé la façon
dont la première ministre avait repris
la main il est encore plus ce soir bien
sûr c'est c'est une victoire à la pyus
pour considérer que d'un point de vue
politicien c'est une sorte de victoire
puisque au final c'est quand même le
texte du Gouvernement essentiellement
qui est qui est préservé mais on voit
bien à quel point l'effet désast
pour pour les citoyens que que nous
sommes qui qui voi bien de quelle
manière le le système institutionnel a
dysfonctionné dans cette affaire et
j'écoutais les les remarques des deux
représentants des des deux grands
anciens partis en réalité patri sont
toujours de partis puissant ici son
toujours des partis puissants mais euh
il porte aussi une part de
responsabilité dans ce qui s dans ce qui
s'est passé n'oublions pas que que la
gauche a voté cette motion de rejet qui
a empêché qu'on a véritblement un un
débat parlementaire fort à l'Assemblée
nationale et dans laquelle leurs
arguments auraient pu être entendus et
du côté des républicains on a vu à quel
point ils se sont livrés à ce jeu de de
manœuvre de négociation qui sont
aujourd'hui incomprises par les Français
donc si vous voulez c'est un peu comme
si toute la classe politique avait
convergé ou conspiré à rendre ce ce ce
ce texte d'abord incompréhensible pour
les Français et à prouvé une fois de
plus que le le système n'arrivait pas à
a fonctionner de manière efficace alors
quand ils vous disent oui mais regardez
on fait le jeu des extrêmes ils font le
jeu des extrêmes collectivement parce
qu'effectivement dans ces cas-là dans
ces situationsl historiquement c'est
toujours les partis extrêmes
protestataires qui qui en profitent et
qui vous disent ben regardez le
Parlement ne fonctionne pas d'ailleurs
la réaction de Marine Le Pen seu une
réforme de la Constitution permettra de
répondre aux enjeux on va en parler dans
un court instant d'une éventuelle
réforme constitutionnelle mais je
voudrais vous entendre et là aussi je
m'appuie un peu sur votre expérience
au sein de haut fonctionnairees au sein
des ministères de l'Intérieur peut-être
sur Géral Haran parce qu'on a un
ministre fragilisé qui a lui-même
annoncé qu'il allait partir après les
Jeux Olympiques est-ce qu'il va tenir
son ministère d'après vous dans les
prochains mois moi il y a quelque chose
qui m'étonne beaucoup c'est que
gérardanin il a publié ce matin les
chiffres sur l'immigration je sais pas
si c'est passé aperçu ou pas c'est quand
de mon point de vue c'est un étrange
jour pour les publier parce que les
chiffres les les derniers chiffres en
datent depuis ce matin c'est 325000
nouvelles cartes de séjour c'està dire
100000 de plus qu'il y a 10 ans donc ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire pourquoi il
a fait ça il aurait pu le programmer
demain la sortie des
chiffres qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'il
veut montrer qu'en fait on a une
immigration qui a beaucoup augmenté et
donc qu'il est impuissant à la contenir
et en même temps il est très content de
la loi qui est voté c'est une espèce de
là aussi de d'argumentaire qui qui qui
est troublant ouais allez je vous
propose un autre élément il y a eu
beaucoup de réactions cet après-midi au
Sénat et une particulièrement virulente
celle de Bruno rotaillot le président du
groupe LR on l'écoute en
longueur le Conseil constitutionnel a
censuré les mesures de fermeté que le
Sénat avait apporté qui avait été
plébiscité je le comprends d'autant
moins qu'il y a des chiffres qui sont
tombés il y a quelques heures des
chiffres records sur l'immigration que
ce soit sur les demandes d'asile que ce
soit sur les visa de premier séjour ou
que ce soit sur les titres de séjour
record donc l'migration elle est en
dehors de tout contrôle le travail du
Sénat c'était précisément des mesures de
fermeté pour diminuer
lesmigration finalement le Conseil
constitutionnel les a censuré sur des
motifs très contestables il faudra nous
expliquer pourquoi l'immigration
familiale n'a rien à voir avec
l'immigration pourquoi les causes
réelles et sérieuses vérifier une cause
réelle et sérieuse d'un étudiant immigré
c'est pas lié à l'immigration pourquoi
les allocations familiales le fait de
les percevoir ça n'est pas lié à
l'immigration et cetera et cetera donc
en fait il y a un vrai problème qui est
que le Conseil constitutionnel refuse
d'appliquer la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 sur le fameux
article 45 sur les Cavers législatifs
pourquoi parce qu'en 2008 en fait la
révision de 2008 tous les travaux le
montrent et le texte le montre on avait
essayé de donner plus le constituant de
l'époque avait donné plus de souplesse
au législateur il fallait non seulement
un lien direct pour que l'amendement
puisse être accepté mais aussi un lien
même indirect et donc il y a un refus
catégorique du Conseil constitutionnel
d'appliquer finalement la Constitution
ce que je crains le plus si vous voulez
c'est que les Français vont voir que
désormais le Parlement est réduit à
l'impuissance vous défendez la rigueur
de votre travail au Sénat il y a pas un
manque de rigueur dans dans ce que vous
avez envoyé comme copie je défends bien
sûr la rigueur puisque on nous censure
sur le fait de nous dire que le
regroupement familial n'a pas de lien
avec l'immigration que par exemple les
études notamment pour les étudiants qui
sont immigrés le fait de vérifier la
réalité de ces études ça n'a pas de lien
par exemple le percevoir des allocations
non contributives les allocations
familiales et les autres ça n'a pas de
lien avec les migration par exemple le
délit de séjour illégal quelqu'un qui
franchit illégalement la frontière il
est clandestin on lui donne une amende
ça n'a rien à voir avec l'immigration
moi je comprends plus est-ce que ça pas
un lien direct et même un indirect selon
la Constitution selon l' qualifier cette
décision comment qualifier exactement ce
elle est contestable elle est absolument
contestable et finalement le Conseil
constitutionnel interdit au
législateurs de prendre des mesures
qu'il intègre à une politique que nous
voulions intégrer une politique globale
efficace de contrôle de la migration
c'est quelque part un dénis du pouvoir
du Parlement du pouvoir du législateur
et donc très rapidement vous dites
nouveau texte et à moyen terme une
rision de la Constitution ça sû bien sûr
il faudra qu'on reprenne ces cavaliers
législatifs selon le Conseil
constitutionnel ça n'en est pas vous
avez compris pourquoi je l'ai montré je
pourrais le faire plus amplement si vous
le souhaitez donc il faut les reprendre
dans un texte déposer ce texte je
demande d'ailleurs au gouvernement de le
faire lui-même parce qu'il y a un double
langage du
gouvernement mais je je pense aussi
qu'il faut une révision
constitutionnelle vous savez je pense
vraiment que la réponse à l'impuissance
dans laquelle nous sommes on est réduit
à l'impuissance on nous interdit de
faire une politique migratoire efficace
ben la réponse à l'impuissance c'est la
démocratie c'est plus de démocrati
c'est-à-dire permettre dans la
constitution de consulter par référendum
le peuple français on y reviendra encore
une fois sur cette question du
référendum mais quand même le le Bruno
taille le parti en général Jean gari
demande un nouveau texte avec les les
dispositions
censurées on voit mal Emmanuel Macron et
Gabriel Atal replongé quand même oui il
faut il faut arrêter de leur demander de
se se suicider en permanence comm comme
le fa l'opposition non en revanche ce
qui ce qu'on aurait pu comprendre c'est
qu'à l'origine soit dissocié les
différents aspects de de ce Tex c'est ce
que disait Patrick canner tout à l'heure
il devait marcher sur de genses mais il
fallait faire de textes différ bien sûr
il fallait faire et peut-être même
plusieurs textes puisqu'il y a la
question du droit du droit au TR au
travail de la nationalisation des de la
ne des des
étudiants ce sont des des des des
secteurs différents qui correspondent
d'ailleurs à des secteurs ministériels
différents qui auraient pu être portés
par des ministres différents donc là on
a voulu notamment parce que le ministre
de l'Intérieur avait quelques ambitions
et et et et qu'il a un peu poussé dans
dans dans cette direction on a voulu
faire un grand Fourtou parce que la
droite sénatoriale avait aussi dit non à
un texte saucissonné avait dit nous on
veut un texte global ça avait été fait
aussi partie de de de ce qu'avait
demandé la droite sénatoriale au moment
où ça avait été évoqué on se rappelle
après la r bien pour ça qu'ils ont aussi
leur responsabé ou Michel auois est-ce
que le le le gouvernement peut a
forcément besoin d'une loi voyez ce que
je veux dire pour être plus efficace en
matière de de contrôle de l'immigration
il a pas forcément besoin d'une loi pour
tous les sujets mais en fait on fait
beaucoup de lois sur des sujets qui
parfois relève d'un simple d'une simple
mesure administrative et on peut
améliorer il y a il y a des
dysfonctionnement administratif qu'on
pour améliorer sur la régularisation
d'ailleurs c'est un peu étrange parce
que on est passé moi j'ai connu la
période quand j'étais préfet où on était
chargé de faire les régularisations à
notre niveau et je pense pas qu'on le
faisait si mal que ça parce qu'après
tout ça permettait toute une série
d'équilibres et on examiner les
situations individuelles à un moment où
sous monsieur Vals on a décidé qu'il
fallait une circulaire non réglementaire
d'ailleurs he qui était juste une
instruction où il fallait régulariser à
5 ans malheureusement ça c'est su ce qui
fait que tous les gens qui avaient 5 ans
de présence ont estimé qu'ils avaient un
droit on a ouvert un droit et là on
arrive à la loi je pense que je pense
que c'est trop quoi je crois qu'on était
pas on a il faut faire attention à pas
mettre de la loi partout voyez on on
pourrait faire beaucoup mieux si on on
avait des des mesures de bon sens
applicaes sur le terreur votre avis
là-dessus anine beina précisément je
pense que il y a pas de gagnant il y a
pas de perdant véritablement ce soir à
l'issue de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel puisque bon le le
Conseil a retenu une acception dure hein
du lien des amendements donc on on a une
inconnue sur la suite du travail
parlementaire ce soir la majorité qui
s'est targué de voir venir
l'inconstitutionnalité sort à court
terme peut-être gagnante mais au fond
comment va-t-elle négocier des accords
désormais et que reste-t-il de cette loi
et au final les citoyens eux-mêmes qui
ne comprennent pas forcément ce
gigantesque théâtre de de marionnette
entre les assemblées parlementaires le
juge constitutionnel qui dit quoi et une
question sans réponse qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire de notre débat sur l'immigration
alors qu'on a les élections européennes
qui sont de plus en plus proche et que
l'on on le sait cette question elle est
centrale pour cette élection à venir
donc euh on on donne de plus en plus
l'impression d'un parlement entravé de
politiques qui sont empêché de gouverner
ça n'est pas la faute du Conseil
constitutionnel mais il faudra vraiment
qu'on se saisissent des sujets qu'on
apprenne à travailler en majorité
relative il est temps les Français ont
besoin de répondre sur ces questions oui
merci beaucoup Charlen je vous libère en
quelque sorte avant la fin de ce débat à
très bientôt sur sur ce plateau
information de cette fin d'après-midi le
président de la République et ça répond
à la demande qu'on qu'on vient
d'entendre exprimer par Bruno rotaillot
à l'instant une nouvelle loi avec les
dispositions censurer et bien la réponse
Emmanuel Macron il demande à Gérald
armanin d'appliquer la loi dans les
meilleurs délais allez on va parler
maintenant de la question de d'une
éventuelle réforme de la Constitution
deux éléments un élément de cette fin
d'après-midi je vous l'ai donner tout à
l'heure nos confrères de l'agence
France- presse Marine Le Pen estime que
seulle une réforme de la Constitution
permettra de répondre aux enjeux elle
l'avait anticipé en quelque sorte ce
matin puisqu'elle imaginait comme nous
tous une une une censure alors plus ou
moins lourde mais une censure du Conseil
constitutionnel et elle plaidait déjà
pour cette réforme on écoute Marine Le
Pen tout de
suite si le Conseil constitutionnel
censure ça veut donc dire qu'il faut
bien une réforme
constitutionnelle pour pouvoir mettre en
place une véritable politique de lutte
contre l'immigration il faut donc bien
constitutionnaliser le droit des
étrangers pour pouvoir décider librement
de la politique d'immigration que l'on
peut faire dans notre pays étant entendu
que la Constitution est supérieure à
toute norme internationale et
j'accueille Audrey va sur ce plateau
bonsoir Audrey il y a le rassemblement
national mais aussi plusieurs
responsables et on en a entendu
quelquesuns qui propose effectivement de
réformer la Constitution en effet Thomas
mais ce n'est pas si simple la
Constitution on ne la change pas d'un
claquement de Doig il faut convoquer les
Français par référendum ou bien réunir
le Parlement c'est-à-dire l'assemblée
plus le Sénat en congrès et obtenir au
moins les 3/5è des suffrages exprimés
mais avant tout ça il faut un texte et
en décembre les républicains les
républicains pardon ont tenté une
première fois leur chance avec un projet
de révision de la Constitution déposée
au Sénat un projet qui prévoyait
d'élargir les conditions de retour de
recours au référendum c'est ce qu'on va
voir aux questions relatives à l'entrée
et au séjour des étrangers en France et
au droits de la nationalité autre
proposition permettre à la France de
déroger aux règles européennes notamment
en matière migratoire oui mais les
républicains se sont heurtés à l'époque
au refus de leur partenaires centristes
au Sénat les centristes dont ils ont
besoin et les centristes qui n'était pas
très à l'aise avec ces deux propositions
d'autant qu'Emmanuel Macron a déjà fermé
la porte à un élargissement du
référendum aux questions migratoires
écoutez la réaction d'Hervé Marseille le
président du groupe Union centriste au
Sénat c'était en décembre dernier il y a
les points sur lesquels nous étions
d'accord d'autres sur les lesquels nous
divergions on parlait de référendum on
parlait bon comme c'est un sujet qui un
peu dépassé euh on peut on peut vouloir
un un référendum mais le le sujet a été
clos par le Président de la République
parce que ça supposerait une révision de
la Constitution qui n'est pas
d'actualité résultat les LR ont retiré
leur texte avant même l'examen pour
éviter un camouflé mais ils sont revenus
à la charge par l'intermédiaire d'une
lettre du président des républicains
Eric cioti envoyé au chef de l'État
cette fois ils ont demandé que soit
inscrit dans la Constitution la mise en
place d'un plafond de plafond migratoire
voté chaque année au Parlement ça doit
vous dire quelque chose Thomas c'est
l'un des points du projet de loi
immigration qui vient d'être censuré par
le Conseil constitutionnel pour
l'instant en tout cas officiellement les
LR n'ont pas reçu de réponse du chef de
l'État merci beaucoup audreet pour pour
tous ces détails j'accueille dans dans
ce débat Paul Cassia qui est professeur
de droit public à parisen Panthéon
Sorbonne et qui est avec nous en duplexe
bonsoir Paul Cassia merci d'avoir euh
accepté notre invitation sur cette
question euh euh on va dire
d'élargissement du référendum au aux euh
aux questions migratoires euh c'est quoi
c'est une course d'obstacle que le
président de République ne veut
manifestement pas courir est-ce que vous
le
comprenez ben déjà il faut quand même
redescendre sur terre et bien réaliser
que la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel n'implique en rien une
réforme de la Constitution parce que ce
qui s'est passé c'est que 32 articles
ont été censurés pour une raison de
procédure de pure procédure
constitutionnelle qu'est-ce que ça ve
dire veut dire concrètement ça veut dire
que ces 32 articles n'ont pas été
examinés quant à leur bien fondés par le
Conseil constitionnel et donc que c 32
articles peuvent être repris soit par
des parlementaires Monsieur rotaillot
Madame Le Pen soit par le gouvernement
donc la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel n'empêche en rien une
révision de l'immigration qui irait plus
loin que ce que le projet de loi euh tel
qu'il a été modifié par le Conseil
constitutionnel a a abouti par ailleurs
le Conseil constitutionnel a validé 10
articles et surtout ce point ne doit pas
être oublié sur les 86 articles le
Conseil constitutionnel ne s'est pas
prononcé sur leur sur la conformité à la
Constitution de 39 d'entre eux h ça veut
dire que d'un côté euh une partie des
articles ont été déclarés
inconstitutionnel pour des raisons de
pure procédure qui peuvent être reprises
et d'un autre côté une grande partie des
articles de de la loi sur l'immigration
n'a pas été contrôlé par le conseil
consal donc le Parlement reste
complètement souverain il n'y a pas lieu
de paniquer il n'y a pas lieu d'en
appeler dès maintenant à une révision de
la Constitution qui en toute en toute
hypothèse serait hypothétique parce que
irréalisable ouais vous vous vous
n'employez pas le terme de de fiasco
législatif ou d'amateurisme ce soir Paul
casscia c'est évidemment parce que quand
32 articles sont censurés pour des
raisons de procédure c'est le baba la
procédure parlementaire et quand c'est
32 articles sont censurés pour des
raisons de forme c'est un échec
collectif de la représentation nationale
mais cet échec collectif elle peut être
corrigé ces 32 articles ils peuvent être
repris dans un Tex dans un texte
ultérieur à l'initiative soit du
Parlement soit du gouvernement donc il
n'y a pas il n'y a pas il y a un fiasco
global mais et tout cela peut-être
corrigé sans révision de la Constitution
il ne faut pas s'emballer et en appeler
dès aujourd'hui à une révision de la
Constitution parce que des articles ont
été censurés sur la base de d'une raison
procédurale c'est complètement grotesque
h euh restez avec nous Paul casscia
votre avis jean- garig on est dans un
une sorte de jeu politique là dans les
demandes de de du RN mais aussi des LR
sû mais totalement et d'ailleurs Paul
Cassia vient de le démontrer d'un point
de vue juridique euh on sait bien
d'ailleurs que cette thématique de de de
la révision constitutionnelle et du
référendum bon fait partie de j'allais
dire de l'articulation de campagne de de
de Marine Le Pen et et des républicains
d'ailleurs à plus ou moins à plus ou
moins long terme mais on sait bien
d'abord ce que l'histoire nous montre ce
que sont les dangers d'abord de la
procédure référendur plébiscitaire et et
qui et qui euh dans en en la matière
apparaîtent totalement hypothétique ça a
été dit aussi parce que il faut une
révision de la Constitution donc une
majorité des 2/3 de t tous les
parlementaires il faut il faut que que
que que les sujets correspondent à ce
que le périmètre de la révision va va
accepter enfin c'est quelque chose qui
apparaît comme comme tout à fait
hypothétique et on revient à ce jeu de
posture c'est-à-dire que cette question
migratoire qui est un enjeu important
pour les Français qui je le rappelle
avait approuvé 60 à 60 % la plupart des
mesures du projet initial cette question
qui est une question importante qui qui
qui n n pas la la question prioritaire
c'estelle du pouvoir d'achat mais enfin
qui est une question qui est devenue
importante pour tous les Français est
soumise à ce jeu de de de posture
politique de petites phrases de de de
propositions dont on sait très bien
qu'elles ne seront pas appliquées et et
ça a conduit effectivement à cette
procédure parlementaire qui a été qui a
abouti à un fiasco voilà les résultats
d'une alors que on a un enjeu majeur
pour pour la société française on a des
jeux de posture des jeux politiciens qui
sont un peu pitoyables fa dire alors je
je vais vous redonner euh si vous nous
rejoignez à l'instant le l'essentiel de
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
32 cavaliers législatif ont été censurés
notamment euh ce qui porte sur le
durcissement de l'accès aux prestations
sociales durcissement du recroutement
familial ou la cion retour c'est le
terme qui est employé pour lesudiants
étrangers et puis il y a trois autres
articles qui ont été censurés
partiellement ou totalement sur le fond
dont l'instauration de quotas
migratoirees fixé par le Parlement ou
alors le fait de relever photo empreinte
digitale d'un clandestin sans son
consentement ou alors le changement de
procédure d'un examen d'un titre de
cjour vous avez promis plusieurs
réactions politiques euh lors de ce
débat en voici une nouvelle toujours
glanée dans les couloir du Sénat euh
Yann brossa sénateur communiste de Paris
qui lui évidemment se félicite de la
décision du conseil c'est une bonne
nouvelle je me réjouis de cette décision
du du Conseil constitutionnel on ne
s'assoit pas sur la Constitution et sur
nos principes fondamentaux et je suis
heureux que le Conseil constitutionnel a
rappelé par exemple que la préférence
nationale n'est pas soluble dans la
République et dans les valeurs de la
République et en l'occurrence je pense
que c'est aussi une une claque
monumentale pour le président de la
République pour les macronistes qui ont
fait le choix de courir après la droite
et et l'extrême droite et en
l'occurrence le Conseil constitutionnel
leur a rappelé que on ne joue pas à ce
jeul impunément alors Yan bossa qui
parle de de grands principe c'est pas
exactement comme ça qu' qu'on peut
comprendre la décision du conse précment
ce qu'on vient d'expliquer c'est que
l'immense majorité c'est sont 32
cavaliers législatifs et ce sont plus de
pur raison de procédure et donc c'est
pas une affaire de principe ça peut tout
à fait revenir dans un nouveau projet de
loi ou une proposition de loi
parlementaire et c'est là qu'on se dit à
droite comme à gauche qu'on se félicite
ou qu'on critique bah c'est pas
forcément pour les bonnes raisons par
rapport à cette décision du Conseil
constitutionnel Michel auouin Le le la
loi va va s'appliquer le président de la
République l'a demandé à son ministre de
de l'intérieur très bien donc il y aura
quoi il y aura on voit bien là les les
les postures des uns et des autres c'est
le terme que vous employez pour les
prochaines semaines on va avoir une
droite parlementaire qui va critiquer en
disant bah vous voyez on n' pas pu
appliquer nos nos décisions et Marine Le
Pen ou Jordan bardellaa qui vont dire
vous voyez bien on peut pas réformer
l'immigration dans ce pays et et
finalement on aura pas beaucoup avancé
oui mais en même temps j'ai envie de
dire comme la pièce de théâatre tout ça
pour ça quoi parce que quand on regarde
bien et si on suit ces sujets depuis
très longtemps on voit on voyait de
toute façon que la loi elle avait
euh comment dire euh elle elle avait
modifié les curseur sur toute une série
d'articles un peu plus d'un côté un peu
plus de l'autre ça fait quand même 20
ans qu'on les bouge comme ça en
permanence tout qu' fait c'était pas une
révolution non plus cette loi quoi donc
on a on a des éléments dedans qui vont
permettre à euh au préfet de de
reconduire à la frontière de façon plus
facile bon on on n'est pas allé très
loin non plus là-dessus on va
régulariser de façon sont plus facile
aussi bon c'est des petites mesures au
bout du compte c'est les petites mesures
l'un des grands sujets de cette cette
question qui est quand même essentielle
hein je pense que tout le monde le
comprend c'est une question qui est
devenue essentielle dans le pays c'est
qu'on a pas de débat oui il débat parce
que la loi aurait dû avoir un débat en
fait on a eu des débats juste sur les
articles de loi qui pour certains
d'entre eux sert assez incompréhensies à
ceux qui sont qui ne sont pas initiés on
n pas eu de débat de fond je pense que
les Français attendent ce débat qui est
par ailleurs inscrit dans la loi lui et
qui n'a pas lieu qui n'a pas
lieu j'y ai participé quelqu fois donc
je peux le dire il y a jamais eu de
débat de fond au Parlement sur la
question migratoire en France qui est un
grand sujet qui aurait mérité une un
vrai débat alors on va voir sur un autre
grand sujet du moment qui est
l'agriculture si on va enfin avoir un
grand débat sur l'agriculture parce que
là pour le coup moi je suis pas
spécialist onond par des mesures si on
répond par des des mesures ponctuelles
voilà on verra bien allez une dernière
réaction celle d'Hervé Marseille le
président du groupe Union centriste ici
au Sénat le groupe Union centriste va
déposer euh rapidement dans les heures
qui viennent une proposition de loi qui
reprendra une partie de ses dispositions
euh afin qu'ell soit soumise à nouveau
au vote du Sénat et de l'Assemblée je ne
doute pas ayant été déjà voté qu'elles
le seront à nouveau Paul Cassia c'est
reparti pour un tour si j'ose dire d'une
façon un peu un peu simpliste un peu euh
trivial avec quelle image finalement du
travail parlementaire dans dans
l'opinion publique française d'après
vous quel bilan vous faites ce soir
c'est vous qui avez le dernier mot de ce
débat euh en ayant entendu les réactions
des parlementaires précédents j'étais
j'étais très inquiet qui fustiggeait le
le Conseil constitutionnel qui appelait
un révision de la Constitution ce que
vient de dire le président Marseille en
quelque sorte me rassure un peu il dit
des choses très banales il dit voilà il
y a une censure pour des motifs de
procédure on va redéposer les euh
dispositions qui ont été S censurer sur
le terrain de la procédure pour qu'elle
soit examinée au fond et ça c'est la
procédure parlementaire normale il peut
y avoir de nouveau un débat à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat sur
les dispositions qui ont été rejetées
comme étant des cavaliers législatifs
par le Conseil constitutionnel donc tout
ça est parfaitement le jeu de la
démocratie du respect de la Constitution
et tout ça peut se faire sans
modification de la Constitution en
revanche ce qui s'est passé lors du vote
de la loi sur l'immigration euh ne
devrait pas se reproduire c'est a une
motion de rejet à l'Assemblée nationale
et le texte s'est cristallisé en CMP
c'est-à-dire à hulos sans débat public
et ce point-là est
disons peu acceptable même si c'est
constitutionnel peu acceptable au regard
des des enjeux démocratiques du texte
merci beaucoup Paul Cassia même si nos
téléspectateurs sont Ferrus de de de
sémantiqu parlementaires CMP commission
mixte parisre je je le rappelle merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat j'ai
rappelé les TI de vos livres Jean Gary
jours heureux quand les Français
rêvaient ensemble aux éditions Paillot
ils sont loin ils sont loin ces jours
heureux Michel auoin le défi d'être
français publié au presse de la cité
merci encore à tous d'avoir participé à
ce débat